so we're all very very familiar with
Donald Trump's lack of diplomatic skill
but today we have a story that takes
this to a new level that actually seems
almost satirical but in a way it's a
refreshing sort of reality that tells us
something arguably positive about Donald
Trump and since these things are so few
and far between I do want to pay some
special attention to it you'll remember
that not long ago the g7 was held in
Biarritz France and we covered all of
the comings and goings and one of the
things that we're now learning about are
the details of a meeting that Donald
Trump was going to have with the
Egyptian president Abdel Fattah al-sisi
and according to The Wall Street Journal
/ multiple people in the room Donald
Trump arrived looking around for el Sisi
and called out where's my favorite
dictator which resulted in what was
described as stunned silence in the room
apparently a joke one set of reactions
was it's not really a joke Donald Trump
loves dictators or at least he loves
authoritarians this includes his praise
of Kim jong-un her Diwan she Putin Saudi
Prince Mohammed bin Salman Duterte etc
he's just saying this guy is my favorite
dictator I love dictators and this guy's
my favorite dictator the argument over
whether it is a joke though I think is
the wrong one this is an extreme example
of a clueless person not knowing how
politics is done yeah it's more of the
same total lack of decorum and diplomacy
that Donald Trump brings to everything
that he does because he's just ignorant
to all of it but there is a way in which
I'm actually relieved to hear Donald
Trump call one of these authoritarians
a dictator even if it's not literally
the truth and I'll explain why in a
second now on the on the facts is LCCC a
dictator he is often called a dictator
he's certainly an authoritarian he gives
the military unchecked power he
overthrew a democratically elected
president in 2013 in a coup to take
power
he's killed hundreds of protesters he's
imprisoned tens of thousands
of dissidents of different kinds there
are allegations of torture of
disappearing journalists and activists
and allegations of abduction I mean
really just horrible terrible terrible
stuff and he is a violent authoritarian
if not a dictator now the reason I find
this refreshing in some way from Donald
Trump is trumps already thrown decorum
out the window he's thrown diplomacy out
the window who cares about that this is
just one more example and what is one
more instance of that at this point in
time I am glad that Donald Trump called
something at least by what it might be
if again if not literally a dictator a
dictatorial authoritarian el Sisi when
it comes to these authoritarian
strongmen I would prefer that Donald
Trump call them what they are or at
least something closer to what they are
instead of merely praising them and
placating them and working to please
them and complimenting them he has
already done it with LCC back in 2017 he
talked about LCCC's doing a great job
and made all sorts of just completely
outrageous statements that ignore the
endless I mean just endless human rights
abuses that we've seen there so is it
embarrassing for Donald Trump to walk
into a room and say where's my favorite
dictator of course it's embarrassing
is it hilariously undec or
of course it is but evidence that Trump
recognizes dictators for what they are
authoritarian for what they are is
slightly positive is this actual praise
of Donald Trump big picture of course
it's not but it arguably in a way it
actually makes his praise of
authoritarian dictatorial types even
worse it would be one thing if Trump
doesn't recognize that that's what they
are and just kind of likes the fact that
he sees them as strong figures Putin
Duterte all of them it's in a sense
worse if he recognizes that they are
dictatorial authoritarians and still
praises them but he's at least calling
things closer to what they are so big
picture it's not like I like Trump now
but I respect the fact that he actually
entered the room and yelled this out
even if it is completely outrageous
diplomatically because it confirms that
Trump recognizes these people for what
they are the fact that he likes them
signals a problem with his moral compass
and moral the moral compass of Trump is
what we'll talk about next but in a
sense he is not as disconnected from
reality as maybe we thought at the end
of last week if I'm missing this if my
take on this miss is something else let
me know but I actually found it
refreshing to hear Donald Trump refer to
LCC at least by something closer to what
he is rather than just a great leader
the way Donald Trump refers to most of
these dictatorial dictatorial
authoritarians let me know what you
think